hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about tinnitus
ringing in the ears okay
it's I'm gonna teach you a technique
it's not mine I didn't develop it
it's I've found some data on the web by
a guy by the name of dr. Jan stride um
okay so it's he developed it I don't
know where he got it from but it seems
to be pretty successful for tinnitus
okay
it's called the finger drumming
technique maybe you already saw it but
I'm gonna alter the technique just a
little bit I mean you can try both ways
but I think this way works a little bit
better it involves kind of a stimulation
of the eighth cranial nerve the eighth
cranial nerve comes out of the brainstem
deep into the skull and it's called the
vestibular cochlear this is the nerve
that affects hearing and if there's a
problem with that nerve you can have
ring as well okay now in my other
techniques that you probably watched or
maybe you haven't a lot of the principle
of getting rid of chronic pain for
example is to work on another part of
the body okay because you have this kind
of the stuck energy that it just keeps
hurting over and over and to release it
you don't work on that air you work on
the mirror-image side this this involves
the same principle so you're gonna be
working on the back part of your skull
that matches this cranial nerve at the
level of the brainstem where it comes
out okay and the first thing you're
gonna do is you're going to take your
fingers like this on the back of the
skull and you're gonna just take your
pointer fingers right on the middle
finger and then just flip them like this
and I'm gonna demonstrate that just like
this okay you're gonna do it like this
okay now here's the thing the location
is very very important if we take a look
at where this nerve exits on the
brainstem it exits at the level of where
the ear is right here with a hole in
your ears right here if you draw a line
and the back part you're going to go
right around the ridge of that what's
called the occiput Ridge it's a little
like if you take your fingers and you
just feel on your skull it'll actually
go and then it just sinks
into your neck right well there's a
little Ridge there the bottom that Ridge
is at the level of where your ear is
that's where you're going to be thumping
or or flipping your fingers and tapping
okay right at that point so you're gonna
take your middle finger and go just
above it and then you're gonna let your
first finger kind of flip off and
together stimulate that point kind of
fairly close to the midline okay so the
first thing you do is you're going to
rate the severity of the ringing or
hissing noise okay so let's just say 10
is like off-the-charts really really bad
one
there's no no ringing at all okay so you
want to first rate it so go ahead and do
that right now what number you go let's
pretend you have a five okay so now
we're going to do this technique he says
to do it for about forty to fifty times
I'm gonna suggest you start up with
doing 20 times and I'm gonna tell you
why in a second so you're gonna do it 20
times so you're gonna do this technique
and just flip your finger in kind of
pulse right at the level of your Ridge
on the occiput okay you're gonna do that
for 20 times then you're gonna rear 8
the severity so it was a 5 let's say now
it's a 4 okay so then you're gonna
repeat this procedure do it 20 more
times ok now reevaluate how is it now
it's a 3 ok do it again and you keep
repeating this until it's completely
gone now you may find that you have to
do this 4 or 5 times to get rid of it
completely there is a chance that it
might not work at all so if it doesn't
work the first time it's probably not
gonna work at all but if it's gonna work
it's gonna work right away okay so
that's the simplicity of it but you want
to keep repeating this and I would do
this every single day until it stays
gone ok
so go ahead and try that put your
comments down below
process it okay Jesus let me do that
over here press the subscribe button
press just press this button right here
subscribe
okay that one right there just do it
right now hey if you're enjoying my
videos press the subscribe button below
and I will keep you updated on the
future events thank you so much